hi there as always
this week's episode of ask mr wonderful
comes from questions
it's a dialogue it's a two-way thing and
what i'm trying to do i got a lot of
questions
i'm trying to gather them into areas
where it's the same question over and
over again so i'm answering as many
people as i can
and listen to this one this is so you
know on trend for what's happening
hi mr wonderful i saw a segment you did
on something called money dispute where
you were talking about tuition fees
i was scheduled to go to college in
boston this fall for my first semester
i had already paid rent for off-campus
housing
both first and last month as everybody
knows the college
is now only offering me online courses
until further notice
my student housing landlord is willing
to let me defer
but not refund my deposit i got it
i'm on a half scholarship so i'm in good
shape on tuition fees
but i'm thinking of deferring for a year
to wait out this pandemic
so i can experience the real classroom
i get it my parents are willing to let
me continue living in my bedroom here at
home
but they want me to start paying rent
any advice
okay well look there's a lot of stuff
going on here so
let's start about let's think about
college what what
is college all about is it about
learning
yeah is it about you know specific
classes you know towards a career yeah
some of that
but i'm going to argue something else
college is a chance for you to meet
people
and develop a network of contacts that
are going to be with you for the rest of
your life
and if truth be told and i'll tell you
my own experience
i don't remember a damn thing about what
i learned in undergrad
or in my mba but i certainly remember
all the people
and so what's being robbed from this
generation during the covet period in my
opinion
is the fact that they are not together
and they are not forming those bonds the
tie and often that's where you meet your
spouse or your significant other or
whatever
it's going through the whole process and
the learning experience of college
so in this case do you stay at home in
your basement or in your bedroom
i don't think so you know i'll tell you
something remarkable this is incredible
data
i was looking at investing in student
housing and then of course the pandemic
came in and said well i don't want to go
there
because no one's going to go and use any
student housing do you know in towns
like boston
they're sold out why the kids are still
coming into town they don't want to live
at home they're in their early 20s and
they want to experience life and meet
others even though they're not
going into the classroom even though
they're going to be learning online
for some indefinite period of time
they're going to experience what it's
like to live in that college town live
in boston
live in new york live in l.a live
anywhere there's a college
in miami whatever they're leaving home
to start their lives
and so my recommendation to you is to do
that you've already
paid you know for the first and last
month and they're not going to give you
that back and you're not going to get it
back that
landlord is probably not going to do
that on the other hand you could move to
boston
start to experience what that sounds
like and i guarantee you're going to
love boston
now it does mean you have to be thinking
about social distancing you can't go
crazy you don't want to get caught up in
this craziness
of partying your face off and then
getting covered bad outcome
but it doesn't mean you can't start to
be careful
and experience life there and meet
others that are doing the same thing you
are that's what's going to happen
when you're walking around boston you're
in a coffee shop in boston you're
meeting students
people just like you it's just packed
it's got to be a million of them there
with all the colleges in boston and the
surrounding areas
so i'm going to say stay on course
stay in class even though it's online
and go cruising through and basically
live your life in the new covent world
but you're going to meet a lot more
people than living at home with your
parents
you've already met your parents you know
who they are and they'll still be your
parents
you can go back and see them any time
like at thanksgiving or whatever
but start your life in boston and for
those of you considering because i got
a lot of questions like this you keep
going
you deal with the blood you're being and
put it this way you're you're dealing
with the hand that you were dealt this
covet thing has really screwed up a lot
of stuff about our society
particularly college but this too will
pass we just don't know when
in the meantime start to experience what
it's like to live by yourself take care
of yourself
even if you're in a dorm which you know
may be closed in some cases
but this is sounds like it's off-campus
housing so
start to live your life there who knows
what you're going to find out who knows
who you're going to meet who knows
what's going to happen next
but that's my advice you just keep on
the path
stay focused you're going to be getting
an education in just a slightly
different way anyways
that was um it's a great question now
let's move on to the second one which
i got a ton of just like this i think
you're going to find this
kind of interesting
this is a question about early
retirement because i guess
covet in the pandemic people are
starting to make some choices about what
they want to do with their lives listen
to this one
i am 58 years old i work at a top
accounting firm in their international
tax department because of the pandemic i
have been working at home for the last
four and a half months
i'm going to have to retire from this
firm with a package when i turned 62.
one of my co-workers who is 59 told me
last week
that he approached management about an
early retirement and they bought him out
with the same package he would have
received at 62.
sounds like a pretty good deal i'm
considering making the same approach can
you give me some advice on the best way
to do it
i'm going to give you some advice on i
don't care whether you've just started
at a job
or whether you're retiring from one i
want to
put on my employment hat and i've been
doing this for a lot of years
interviewed a lot of people my time
hired and fired many
if you're planning on retiring if you're
planning on making a move
to another company if you're planning on
leaving the job for
any reason at whatever age you are
here's rule number one
shut your mouth don't talk to anybody
about it
that works with you never never disclose
what your thoughts are
why the minute people think you're
retiring the minute they think you're
checking out the minute
they think you're not on course and
staying with the mandate of the job you
have
your status within that company
collapses immediately and
word spreads like wildfire that's just
the way it works
and it will happen to you the only
people you should be talking to about
your career are those you completely
trust to keep their mouth
shut completely quiet could be your
parents could be your brother your
sister
or somebody else you don't work with
because the minute you disclose it to
anybody you work with
you should assume everybody knows and
that is not a good negotiating position
if you want to make a move
that's rule number one number two if
you're the person that wants to retire
okay you basically go in
on a monday with the assumption you're
leaving that friday
because that's what they want to do to
you if you're trying to get the same
package the other person got
and you know that's available it's good
that you know that and you're not yet 62
in this case and you'd like to
renegotiate something this is the time
to do it because companies are trying to
figure out
how to reduce costs at this time very
often the cost
of giving your package is not accounted
for the same way as an ongoing cost of
keeping you as an employee
which is why they might be willing to do
it now during this covet period
that's very very important but you have
to make the assumption
that once you bring it up and you start
that negotiation there's only
one path for you and that's out the door
but the opportunity is for you to go and
say look i'm interested in retiring i
heard about that other package
that my co-worker got i'd like the same
deal if you're willing to do it we can
agree on it right now i'm checking out
here on friday
okay now for the person that's thinking
of moving to another company
and you want to go see your boss to talk
about it don't do that
do not do that the only meeting you're
having with your boss is after you've
made the 100
decision that you're leaving and you
walk in and tell them that and you
should make the assumption
you're leaving 15 minutes later because
that's in financial services
that's what happens they put all your
stuff in a box it's not adversarial it's
just the way it is and they walk you out
the door
they take away your clearance card your
security pass and you're out of there
that's why in all of these decisions
about making
career changes you keep it to yourself
until you've already committed
the change until it's in your head that
you know you're going to do this thing
and there's no turning back you're doing
it and you're going into that office and
you're telling them your intentions
and there's only one way after that
you're going to execute on what you
decided to do
so the better thing to do in thinking
about moving a lateral move or a move to
a better job for a competitor or
whatever
is really explore that as quietly as you
can
get it in writing get the offer in
writing
so there's no dispute after you've made
your big move
as to what you were promised get it in
writing let me say it one more time
get it in writing get an offer in
writing so that everything you know you
thought you understood
you do and it's written down then you
walk in
and you're out of there in 20 minutes
very very important basically
there's a common theme here regarding
employment you don't negotiate your
career path with your
boss or your peers you do that on your
own
in your head or with people you trust
that are not going to talk to anybody
else
and once you've made that decision once
you know the direction you're going
then you make your move that's when you
do it because you know with certainty
that morning your life's going to change
you're out of that business and you're
on to a new one either you've retired
or you've made your move but get all
your ducks in order before you do it
this will help you immensely think that
through this is very important i've done
it a thousand times
talk to people that come in to see me
look boss i've been thinking about
making a move can you sweep my offer
over here
i i get rid of those people five minutes
they're not on board anymore
don't let that happen to you something
to think about if you're retiring
there's a fantastic side hustle emerging
in america
now and it's all around the world too
because the world is digitizing at a
really rapid rate because of covid
there's all kinds of new jobs on the
artsy side let me explain what i'm
talking about
if a company was selling 50 of its
products to retail
it was basically going through
distribution and selling in a retail
location today
much of that has gone away because the
stores are closed as a result of coving
so now companies want to tell stories
they want to use instagram they want to
use facebook they want to go online
they want to take pictures of their
products they want to video their
their their images so they're really
rich in content about the service or the
product they're trying to sell
that takes art that takes great people
that have
photographic skills video skills editing
skills sound skills
if you have any of those they were
considered to be lesser in terms of
demand in the past and very
very often people would sell their
services for a very low price
not today if you're a good video editor
you're in hot demand if you're a great
photographer of products you're in hot
demand
if you know how to construct digital
editing or
or mix video or sound you can find a
side hustle helping a company that does
that or helping a company that's built a
department to do just that
because there's so much digital activity
going on right now
we're using editors all around the place
now to cut our content for all of my
companies
so that we can do videos 59 seconds 30
seconds 15 seconds
two minutes all these different
platforms have different rules you can
put a 10 minute video up on it
on linkedin and on facebook but you
can't do that on insta
so you have to have different formats
and that's done with editing
so if you're one of those people that's
a great career for you right now and can
lead to a much bigger job over time
i've always said this about work there's
the discipline of business and it's very
binary
either you make money or lose money it's
very digital plus one
negative one that kind of thing and then
there's the art the ying and the yang of
the creative aspect
what makes a great manager what makes a
great business person a great
entrepreneur
someone who's combined both music the
arts video photography with the
discipline of managing a business
it's a great combination and it's all
coming to the fore now it's coming to
the front
because of the digitization of the
entire global economy
it takes art to tell a story it takes
video it takes sound it takes an image
and that's all the art side the left
side of the brain
it's a wonderful thing to think about
and a great new opportunity
for artists to make money like never
before i wish you all well on that one
now my third question kind of is a nice
little foray into this idea of art
it's it's an interesting question i've
got it many many times i've never never
decided to answer it
but i wanted to and let me just tell you
what it is here
i'm an early follower of your youtube
channel you are always
talking about watches as investments how
can they be investments if you never
sell any of them
good question good point also what is
the point of buying more than one watch
when your phone is far more
accurate in keeping time how do you
decide what watch to buy next
i ask this because i'm considering
buying a mechanical men's watch
to wear as oversized jewelry
thank you becky so becky is going to
buy a man's large format watch and wear
it which is a
hot trend in watches let's get to the
issue around
i don't buy watches as investment
because becky's right i never sell them
i consider them collecting art and to me
a watch is about the dial
i don't own just one brand of watch i
own many different brands and i've
always been
someone who studies the dial now one of
the most popular watches in my wardrobe
is the
rolex daytona because the dial you can
see against a red van hell just pops
it looks great with a black suit the
dial just accelerates
visually and that to me is the hallmark
of a great dial but there's many other
great dials
and so for example as i'm preparing to
go and shoot
shark tank i can't take my whole watch
collection with me but this year i'll be
taking
eight so i thought for becky i would
actually walk through the process with
you
of what it's like to actually choose a
portfolio
of eight different watches knowing that
you're trying to mix and match
and make a statement with with the dials
because the collecting of watches for me
is
is that a unique dial do i have a dial
like that in the collection
as i like to call it le collection do i
have something
in there that's not the same or is this
something unique and if it's unique
it piques my interest as a as a watch
collector
but watch this and you'll see the agony
i've gone through to choose the what i
call shark tank eight for this season
the eight pieces that are all unique all
have different dials
all have red bands because i wear red
bands for continuity
on television i have many watches that
don't have red bands i just never wear
them on tv
as you'll see but these are the eight
that i'm going to be wearing for this
season i hope you enjoy this
and if you're into watches as becky is
and we're just exploring
of getting into collecting think about
it as
art because you don't need a watch to
tell time your phone becky's right is
way better
in telling time more accurate but a
mechanical watch is a piece of
art it has an emotional connection with
its owner the reason becky wants to get
an oversized man's watch
is it looks cool my wife and daughter do
the same thing they're always stealing
from my collection
big oversized men's watches with big
bands and wearing them out on the town
because they look cool
of course they look cool it's a fashion
statement it's a statement of art and
the dials are unique and interesting
i'm always keeping an eye on my
collection and i always know when one's
missing exactly where it is it's not
stolen it's on my wife's wrist
she just hates red bands so that's
another way that i keep her out of there
but for me what becky's going through is
a desire to
to explore the art to dial the
experience of wearing a mechanical watch
and for those of you that are interested
i i highly recommend it it's just sheer
fun
you know it it's it's something you
pursue as a hobby but it's really the
yin and yang of art
you don't need a watch but it's good for
the soul
till next time take care
okay now something i really enjoy doing
we're just about to shoot shark tank
season 12.
but there's wardrobe involved and the
way shark tank works is there's many
different panels
different guest sharks different
configurations of sharks and that means
wardrobe can change
i avoid that problem by always wearing
the same thing
black tie tie pin white
shirt crisp dark suit i got 25 of them
that's my shark tank uniform in fact i
wear that a lot i like the way it looks
and it's easy to remember every morning
and it makes it very easy for the
editors to cut between different
pods however i don't wear the same watch
you'll always see in each different pod
i'll wear a different watch this year i
have to choose between
eight out of my collection eight watches
now i already know what i'm gonna wear
in cufflinks
i love these skulls they're just
absolutely gorgeous you've seen them in
other seasons before
and the thai pins i have one in gold and
one in silver
based on what i'm going to need
on the dial of the watch those are
silver skulls
and i often use gold cufflinks when the
watch case is gold rose gold or
yellow gold depending on i also have
eight different pens
that i use in these different pods and i
match the pen
to the watch but it's the watch
selection
that gets complicated this is a subset
of my collection here
there are many different brands but the
key to a watch
is its dial these are all unique i
collect watches based on how unique the
dials are
the dial in a watch tells the story so
i've got to choose eight out of this
subset of the collection
now the go-to i've been using for season
after season
because it's such a spectacular dial is
the classic rolex daytona
fondly known as the pandex it now has a
black ceramic which just goes
perfectly with my suit the white dial
pops
and as you know i only wear red bands on
television so i have to go through this
dance with all the manufacturers
in getting specially custom-made red
bands for each of my pieces
otherwise it won't appear on television
it doesn't mean i don't own watches
that don't have red bands but they won't
be on television so
this carche i love this it's one of my
very first watches but unfortunately
won't be on tv so let's take that out of
the mix
this incredible patek i love it the
nautilus
fantastic piece but won't be on
television
then we start to sub look at the subsets
here we know with certainty in my view
that you know looking at different
pieces
you want diversity in the actual dials
i know i'm going back to the daytona
so it's going to be one of the eight so
right out of the gate let's put it
forward
it's up there why because it's a
perennial favorite
it's been on the show in many many
seasons many different episodes it's
probably one of the stars
of my wardrobe over the years and i just
love it i love the i love the dial i
love it
and it's a rolex so we've got rolex
covered okay
now i'm looking for uniqueness and
obviously the collection changes as the
year goes on i bring pieces into the
collection i rarely ever sell anything
so there's always new things to choose
from this style
is a ming a new discovery this year one
of the hottest micro brands in the world
you can go online look it up it's an
incredible story
but the dial is remarkable it's a
stunner people that see it ask me about
it all the time
so i'm going to include the ming in this
year's shoot so that's number two
on the hit parade so we've got a rolex
we got a ming
i told you this is going to be fun
now another piece i acquired this year
which is absolutely fascinating
comes from a collector that you know
taught me a little bit about stretching
outside of switzerland
so this piece is
a language zeit work a digital dial even
though it's a mechanical watch an
extraordinary piece again with a red
band on it
this has never been worn on shark tank
before but i think viewers are going to
be intrigued with this because it's such
an unusual dial
again going for the dial trying to
really make a statement with the dial
and i think it's going to work just
terrific with any red pen
this subtle grayness in the beautiful
tones inside the dial
and the fact that you can read the time
digitally even though it's a mechanical
watch can you imagine how complicated
the movement is in this thing
it's beautiful it's a piece of art but
again deserves to be in season 12 so
that's number three
on the hit parade also
has already appeared last year but i
really really love
the face the dial on this perpetual
ed marpiquet this is their new
1159 collection i think there was a
hundred of these made
in gold and i think it's just a striking
dial and i think i want to bring it back
for you know a new appearance again if
you want to put it that way
repeat performance so to speak so let's
make that number
four that's interesting number four on
the hit parade
so we've got four dials now all
completely different
there's another brand that has some
remarkable does we talk about dials
fp journey i mean
how extraordinary is the dial on this
piece
you don't see this very often it's
subtle
it looks beautiful with a red band but
there's so much going on on the dial i
think it really captures the eye
and i think this year it's got to be on
the show i just love this piece
it's you know jordan makes crazy watches
and if you're into this style i have
many jordans but this one definitely
i think i want to have on the show
the resonance i mean it's a classic
beautiful
there we have it five
ah now it gets more complicated we have
to go for total
uniqueness in terms of what we're
bringing to the next style because we
have to keep everything different
that's a beautiful piece too the elegant
it's just a striking blue dial again in
fpjorn
worth considering and of course the
classic royal oak ap
also lovely but again we're looking for
diversity diversity diversity
oh i mean this style is just
i'm kind of making this decision with
you as we go through it but
grand seiko stunning
i mean the rich red of this lacquer is
just
saying that's an upset that comes into
the collection this year
one two three four five six two more
pieces
two more you know it's like choosing
amongst children it's really difficult
you want good representation across the
maisons
but you really really want to be
selective on what you're doing with the
dials
oh my goodness it's tough it's really
tough this
is also striking you know another grand
seiko just a brilliant dial beautifully
polished
but you know you can't take everything
you got to choose eight
you know it's it's always a tough
decision you're trying to decide oh my
goodness
but i also want good diversity across
the different brands here
i love it it's coming in basketball
constantine
beautiful blue face red band can't beat
it
one two three four five six seven
uh tough
tough tough tough
so hard to choose so hard to choose
reverso a classic
the panerai people love panerai too but
i've worn it in many seasons so
i'm trying to you know keep a mix going
here carche
roadster classic
here's another rolex but no red band so
i won't be taking that on television
but there's so many fantastic rolexes
too
yup the batman where are you
there we are classic look spectacular
red band
the pepsi these are the nicknames of
these watches
this is the daytona with a with a black
face
um versus the white face also classic
beauty but i think the white face
really works with the white shirt so we
stick with that
gotta pick one more you gotta hand it to
joran
this is the elegant a beautiful face
but the blue this is
this blue dial spectacular the elegance
is doing its thing it's actually
finding the right time because i moved
it
beautiful piece you know a very striking
dial it's between these two really i
think i'm going to bring another journey
on set
so what do i like do i like le blue
the blue dial do i like the elegant i
like them both
but i can only take eight decisions
decisions
in this case i think i'm going with blue
by the way
rumored to be a piece that putin wears
stunning lovely
there we have it those are season
12 mr wonderful
watches one two three four five six
seven eight we're done
ah it's tough to decide it really is
but that's it for this season that work
is done
thanks for joining